et maman qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle
fait la cuisine et elle s'occupe de
Sarah de ça alors est de toi aussi oui
et alors est-ce qu'elle fait bien la
cuisine oui qu'est-ce qu'elle fait de
bon à la cuisine du jambon de la viande
des nouille
et et en dessert qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
au cuire de elle fait rien il y a pas de
dessert tu manges pas de dessert à la
maison si qu'est-ce que c'est que tu
manges comme des
desour
desour et bien moi je peux dire que
lesourt d'Orléan c'est pas n'importe
quoi des quoi
des bah oui et bien moi je connais parce
que j'en mange aussi
des et c'est bon hein oui tu les prends
naturel ou avec des fruits
naturel naturel